Shmuel, thank you so much
for being with me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thanks, Michael.
My pleasure.
Appreciate your project.
Thank you. Okay.
So, we already started this interview.
I forgot to hit record,
but it's great because it's part
of this whole informality.
Shmuel, we know each other
from J-Ventures,
a wonderful fund that we're both at.
And what I mentioned before
is that I just get so inspired every time
by senior insights and your motivation
and your passion for helping early stage
startups in and out of the fund.
So just to thank you for
everything that you're teaching me
through that great program.
And I'm really excited to learn
over these 20 minutes
who you are a little bit better.
So, let's get right back
to where we were.
Shmuel, who are you?
Okay. So, if I have to define myself
and I think I said it
before you forgot to record.
I am a computer architect,
that's how I define myself.
You started with interview.
I just want to mention.
I would venture to say that while
at the beginning of my career,
I was thinking that I'm an introvert.
Well, all engineers need to be.
I'm not exactly an introvert.
I'm not going to spend a lot of time.
But at a certain point of my career,
when I'll venture to say,
was pushed into it
into engineering management.
I was a chip designer.
I was doing some cash control errors.
I was told, "Hey, take a team. Lead it. etc."
And one of the things I learned
and if you ask what makes me tick,
I'm a product guy.
Which means
somebody has to use the product.
And when it occurred to me
subconsciously maybe
that I can do it with a team.
It takes a village
Whatever tactic it is.
Better than an individual contributor.
I continued as an engineering leader.
Maybe unique engineering leader
and never left the technology.
But never forgot that
I have to trust people
who are smarter than me.
I'll take all a small task.
But I see the big picture.
You mentioned you said
you were pushed into it.
What does that mean?
What does it mean?
Paint me the picture.
Take me back in time.
Okay. So, long answer.
How many in-directional
I'll have to remember.
How many pushes and then
how many pops off the stock.
But came to the states as a young engineer,
part of an Israeli startup.
One of the first companies in Israel
that was called the startup.
I'm talking early 80s.
Wow.
I am not going in who the investor was.
It was all black and white back then. Right?
It was, I was a chip designer,
but we actually use chisels to
divide carving on the rocks.
Yeah, I can do jokes as good as you.
But to the point of,
I'm sorry, I apologize.
You have the erase button.
So, I came here as a young engineer.
I mean, maybe another in-directional.
I climb out of it as alternate hole.
Technion graduate.
I started to work at a large
government military research institute.
Okay.
In Israel, you could call it Rafael.
So. And the reason I joined
I was third year in the Technion.
They come and say, "You join."
Was kind of the plan.
Hey, plans, plans never happen.
Kind of the plan.
Okay, what I'm doing there,
which had nothing to do with computers,
but it was pattern recognition,
video analysis, etc.
We had video at that time.
But yeah, it will be my
thesis and then maybe PFT.
Anyway, I joined the startup
that was doing super many,
unique super many in the early 80s.
Never looked back.
Came to this country
kicking and screaming.
Really.
I mean I just got married
couple of months before
we bake the first son.
My wife had to take a leave of absence
and 38 years after it I'm still here.
But now going back,
I'd never forget
the pops and pushes are on the stock.
What does I mean push?
So, I came here.
I started to work as a designer
for an American company,
who required the Israeli startup,
with colleagues of mine.
And my domain was whatever,
doing the cash controller.
At a certain point,
and I had no pretension.
I didn't even know I'm staying.
At a certain point.
Push means,
my mentor at that time,
and I use the term mentor a lot
because if I'll ever write a book color,
I get about all the people I learned from
basically said,
"You should lead the team."
And then it was,
"We'll make you a manager."
And then I was, when I say
kicking and screaming again,
the pushed was,
"No, I just want to write test vectors
to what I design."
I hope I explained the push.
So, somebody saw something and,
And here you are after--
And he was right.
Right. Okay.
So, now fast forward.
You've been an SVP at quite
a few organizations.
Huge organizations.
So, talk to me a little bit about
what is the role
of a senior vice president of engineering?
What does that even mean?
What does it mean?
So, huge means after the acquisitions,
I mean, I have been part of three startups.
All the companies that are startup,
they ended in acquisition.
Usually I didn't stay.
At the current one I stayed.
Not gonna ask why.
But what does it mean?
It means responsibility
for delivering the product.
I'm not the architect anymore,
although I try to remain as technical.
It means you asked,
you said that at the end
you lost me, but,
it means re-fix, it means people,
because--
you're already giving me
the answer for them.
This is cheating.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm not defining myself.
But it means people.
It means a project
which has a timeline,
nothing words explained, etc.
And it means a product.
Which means working with
product management, the customers, etc.
to define the MVP, etc.
It's all about the delivery.
Right.
But when I say people,
I never forget that
an engineering leader,
and I had a term S VP, VP, etc.
It's really an engineering leadership
is about people.
And remembering that
you delegate to people who are,
I hate the term
because we don't do a competition,
smarter than you.
And you delegate to people
who cover for your weaknesses.
Right. Okay.
But not passes all the strengths
and weaknesses.
But that's really
the definition of the job.
And between those
in those three startups,
depending where they invest
or where
and two of them almost die.
Then I had to help redefine the company.
By the way, when I say I,
it's just a habit.
But I remember that.
It's never I.
It's us.
But.
Shmuel, how many people
are you leading now?
About 300.
I've led a thousand before.
But you don't lead them directly.
But Shmuel, you're defining the culture.
You're defining what it means
to deliver the product.
How do you lead a thousand people?
A thousand people?
It doesn't matter if it's direct or
if there is different steps
of the pyramid.
And then they're looking at you
as the person who's defining
the strategy and trajectory.
Is as simple as one word, maybe two.
And again,
clarity.
You'll have to explain
what's the true north,
because in order to get to a product,
if it's an innovative product,
there are challenges.
You are going to remember
that you're not gonna,
So, you have to make sure
you are getting into the true north.
You have to help them realize.
Where do you move resources
and one task to another?
When I say true north
think how a chimpanzee or a gorilla
moves in the jungle.
If you watch him,
you'll see he jumped from limb to limb,
from tree to tree.
He knows where your key is going.
My job was to make sure
that we know where we are going.
Because at certain times at the project,
you don't know where you're going.
Clarity is key.
What really do we need to expect?
Run interference.
Because especially in large company,
accurate acquisitions,
there is a huge.
Contingency of people
who are trying to help you,
but they are not stakeholders.
All right.
Let's leave it at this.
At the startup, it's easy.
It's small.
All the management team came together.
It's much easier to do a project
with 10 engineers.
And that's how it started.
And then grow to a hundred.
Then work on a large company.
And last but not least,
I'm sorry if I'm preaching,
No no no.
Especially with engineers.
They simply don't send videos,
don't behave as an exec.
I was told I'm not the right exec.
Which is true.
But apparently, I do something right.
But I am not a typical,
I'm not a typical exec.
I don't communicate by long e-mails.
I don't send long e-mails.
You stand in front of them.
You try to do some small coffee gatherings.
Well, I can't now so I do it at Zoom.
I need to change my headset
because the headset is now glued to me.
But back to what I was saying.
They remember what you say.
So, say what do you mean,
mean what you say,
and deliver.
Because it's all about trust in my opinion.
Amazing. And I think that's inspiring to hear
at a time when even in small companies
and I have the benefit of also seeing
a lot of my friends go into all these
different startups.
And here in Palo Alto,
there's a lot of excitement over
everything that's happening.
And even somebody who's in a leadership role
in the tiniest startup.
I mean, people especially I think
my generation.
I guess I think a little bit
more than previous generations,
enjoyed the titles
and enjoy the responsibility.
And it comes across also
within the workforce, I think.
At least from what my friends
are telling me,
that why is that
my team leader of five
sending me these crazy pitches
and the slide deck
to represent a simple idea.
And why wouldn't they do
a one on one with me?
And which is exactly what
you are saying here.
And again, I am atypical.
I mean it.
I'm not saying I'm better
or worse or whatever.
That's my style.
It worked for me.
I can't tell you if it works for others.
A lot of my colleagues are
now corporate America.
I used corporate America.
I work a lot of Japan.
It's a corporate worldwide which is
that means that's it.
And then there is a video
and a Zoom to 100 people.
I don't.
But I don't and I admit it.
It's my weakness.
I'm not good at it.
I am much better at one on one.
The other thing to remember
and again, when I learned it,
and that was my failure at the beginning,
when I learned it things started to work.
Check the ego at the door.
There was a period,
I would say, in the late 80s, mid 90s.
That I was thinking
I'm the smartest guy walking the planet.
Because I can design supercomputers,
whatever.
And credit to friends.
Credit to my wife for the two kids.
Credit to who told me that,
Okay.
Well, about to make you a raise.
My shit does stink.
And that was quiet and education.
And I realized I have an ego.
Well, all successful people have egos.
If you don't learn
to check them at the door.
Some humility.
You're not gonna be successful.
I mean, others are.
But it didn't work for me.
Shmuel, and it goes hand-in-hand
with what you told me
right before we started.
Which was you look at millennials
who are coming in as engineers
and you realize
two pretty contradicting things
yet complimentary things. Right?
Okay. So, let me start at the high level.
So, they were born with computers.
I wasn't.
I never saw a computer until my
third year at the Technion.
Okay. It shows my age.
But I told you that I came
here in the early 80s.
I was getting my dad, Billy,
and I had some big simulation,
RF simulation in Fortrun.
And guess what?
The Technion had that time a 37168.
And I had to program it on punch cards
and go and submit the job.
And learn stuff like job control language.
And one of my colleagues Sonny said,
"Why don't you have an accountant TSO?"
And I go, "What's TSO?"
"Oh, it's a time-sharing option."
"Good. How do I get it?"
"Oh, you'll have to study
computer science."
So basically, I had computer science
and never looked back.
But now to the point.
So, I didn't grow up with computers,
but I was lucky,
Most of my professional fun,
I almost say career
and I hate that term,
but call it career,
was in the 80s and the 90s.
And as far as I'm concerned,
that's the decade
where computer architecture
was defined.
And it gave me a foundation
that I still use
because I was doing cash controllers
and I was a designer
on a risk processors
and their operating system
was at that time
Unix System V and etc, etc.
I became a much better software person,
system person,
because I understood
operating systems to adapt
that only a designer of processors
could understand.
Now I say,
Okay, that's the advantage.
And that's what I use now
to obstruct stuff at a higher level.
But when I say that your generation
is much better than me
and I envy you,
I struggle with the simplicity
where you guys take micro services
and combine it to Google analytics
and whatever
and blah, blah, blah, blah.
I don't say my kid can write in python.
I struggled with it.
I mean, but at a certain point
I realized that I can help
because I can understand stuff
that they don't.
Because it's so natural.
So, the foundation of
how the processor works
and how the operating system works,
and I don't care
is it virtualize or containerize,
or in the cloud
still gives me an advantage.
I hope I answer why I have both
an advantage and a disadvantage.
100%, 100%
I'm a dinosaur.
But I'm lucky that dinosaur,
Sorry, but I'm lucky that
my professional learning
was at the decade that processors
took a giant leap.
Definitely. I think one of the things
that I grew up with in my house,
which was also,
I come from a house where
I have quite a strong tech presence
and great mentorship.
And one of the things that
I was always taught
from very young
is first to get the foundation.
Get to really understand
the foundations.
Learn the advanced mathematics,
understand how things are happening,
and then you'll be able
to apply these things at an abstract
later on whatever technologies.
And what I do see and I agree with you
is that a lot of a lot of engineers today,
they jump straight into Python and JavaScript
and today it's all commoditize.
It's very easy to go and write website
or run an application.
It's much harder to do the complex
and really cool stuff
because that's where the foundation kicks in.
So, I completely agree.
Shmuel, what are you so excited about now
with working with early stage startups?
So, you've been with startups yourself
as an executive,
but now you're also helping invest
and advise startups.
So, talk to me a little bit about this
this interest of yours that is
over the past decade or so.
So, working with startups again,
mostly advisory role.
That means on demand.
Nobody wants your advice
unless they have a need.
So, it goes everywhere from,
Hey, can you look at this problem
and use your brain to tell me?
I mean, most of advice means,
put it for me,
[--],
doing the same thing
and expecting different results.
The definition of lunacy.
A lot of time it's about sharing.
I hate to advice.
I don't give advice.
It's basically wrong.
But trying to use example and say,
here is what I have learned.
That's what the business side,
is the what the way I help.
On the technology.
Only when I asked to do a deep dive.
We talked about the foundation.
And yeah, I agree with you
and thanks for sharing with me.
I mean I didn't even know
I wanna do that I believe.
I started to physics and math
and whatever,
but credit to the Technion
I think still now.
But definitely at that time,
the foundation is much stronger than,
Hey, here is a quarter and we'll teach you
how to write JavaScript.
And nothing against it,
again, I envy those guys.
But at the end the really cool stuff
is the foundation.
The cool stuff is the foundation.
And that's what I'm trying to help with.
And that's not one semester
of learning how to do JavaScript.
Of course. Shmuel,
we're almost out of time.
I don't know why I called it
20-minute leaders.
I could have called it 30-minute leaders.
And I would have one 10 minutes more
with every person.
Stay on time.
I do have to ask you my last question.
Three words that you would
use to describe yourself.
Okay.
It's the hardest one.
Let's speak from 10.
So,
Direct.
Although I am American now.
So, I took American in business.
But that DNA has never.
Innovative.
Which is trying to, um.
Passionate.
I was told sometimes, "Relax, okay."
The passion will never disappear.
Humble is my word for you Shmuel.
It's extraordinary.
All the things that you've done
and you're still doing
yet you're here talking
with so much humility about everything.
And it really resonates.
So, thank you for the inspiration
and thank you for teaching me so much
through working together at J-Ventures.
It's really fantastic.
And thank you.
That's it.
Thank you, Michael.
Thanks for what you're doing.
Take care.